foreign
Is With Us in Tulsa Oklahoma hi Elaine
hi what's up
what I'm calling about is my my stepson
who whom I love as much as I do my own
son
we've been very close and uh he has come
to me for some money
a large sum this time and uh
I just
don't know
if he's ever going to learn how to do
his money I I don't know what to do how
do you want to help him how old is he
60.
62.
83 almost 84. wow
I know I'm old no no you sound like
you're 45 yeah and and I'm when I had a
stepson I didn't have 62 in my head okay
um so how much large sum is he asking
for
uh 69 000 for what
well he he gave me a list
of bills and uh
for mortgage payments on his house and
10 acres and and mortgage payments on
some land and credit cards and student
loans and a Truck
okay if he's 22 I kind of get it
I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around how you're 62 and you still ask
Mommy for money
I'm really struggling with that what's
his problem does he not work much
he works all the time and his wife works
what do they do with all their money
I that's one question I did not ask him
um
and I should have when we sat down to
talk about this you know what he's going
to say
I don't know
because he doesn't know he doesn't
probably yeah he has absolutely no plan
because no one plans to make a mess like
he has made
so how much money have uh how how long
have you been giving him money
oh uh
because I've given me money ever since
his dad died but you know off on home
but it's been small amounts
how long uh
about nine years yeah okay
and how much money do you have hon
well uh my husband uh
and I loved him dearly he left me a
trust
right now and it is 335
000 797.
uh I had Social Security
[Music]
okay
all right so out of the trust I get uh
monthly I get 2 800 a month so where are
you gonna get sixty nine thousand
dollars
however I'd have to take it out of this
this trust oh you could take it out of
the trust okay all right
so um and you're 82 and you are you in
ill health
well I'm 84. almost 84. you sound like
you're in great health
well uh I've had a heart attack and a
couple of light strokes and I've been
diagnosed with severe
uh
mid-generative Edition so what happens
to this what happens to this what
happens to this trust when you pass
he gets it he gets it there's no your
own there's no other siblings or oh
because it was in his dad's name before
the other siblings is out okay why take
all the lawsuit on me he filed a lawsuit
on me to get the estate and my home
you so the trust you're leaving to the
the steps on you don't have you said
your own so you don't have a son well we
went through the courts and we bought
his older brother out
uh but do you have any do you have any
children
I have
a daughter and a son why are they not
getting part of the trust
well because it was made out to
my husband's Sons okay all right because
it was his money okay it was his money
and he wanted left through to them after
you pass I got you yes okay and then one
of them's out because he tried to mess
it over I got you okay wow okay so here
here's what you can do
um I don't know if you will because
you're a very sweet lady and I don't
know if you're too sweet or not
I want you to be so sweet that you love
this 62 year old better than you have
loved him because by giving him money
you have not been loving him well you've
allowed him to continue to misbehave you
gave a drunk a drink
does that make sense
and you know that that's why you called
me that's why you call me because you
know that
oddly enough I'm his age and that's
weird okay that's so weird but anyway
yeah um so the the thing is anytime
you've got someone who's perpetually
coming to you for money and they
um
and you give them money and it doesn't
help them then you become and and nice
people or who does this not mean people
uh you become what we call an enabler
you're giving a drunk a drink
and so you've enabled him and he's
gotten Bolder and Bolder and Bolder as
he's gone along and so
um I'm AF here's what you say I talk to
my financial counselor because you did
I'm him
and he said I don't have enough money to
give you the 69 000 because you don't
you don't have that much money
you need the money that you have for the
for your life
now if there's money left over when
you're gone you can leave it to him
that's fine but you don't have 69 000 to
give him even if you did it wouldn't be
good for him it's not proven to be good
for him in the past
so what I would do is this I would offer
to help him
um as he goes through Financial Peace
University and I'm going to pay for it
and give it to you for free I'm going to
put you on hold and Austin's going to
give it to you to give to him if he goes
to the class and documents to you that
he pays off a bill you will match him
up to
what he pays off and so instead of 69
000 he's going to get 30 000 if he
changes his habits and pays bills off
and if he goes through this class if he
doesn't do those things he gets zero
until you die